1:01 come true oh my god car styling -
look at the car coming - hitter child 1
you go coming at you like a fight let's
go backwards in who's called it a run
Ellen was telling the story about how
she got hit by a car or something like
that it kind of alluded to the fact that
she it was because she got into a fight
but what she used
this is report for fighting she said
Rumble okay what am I so old I am
who the [ __ ] calls fighting a rumble how
old would you find like this is [ __ ] man
you see I've never been at a rumble
before I've been in the fight I don't
know what the [ __ ] a rumble is you what
a rumble is a rumble is what Popeye the
sailorman gets into when he gets little
Rumble well they came with bad
they came with bass is not a rumble
called salt okay I came to rumble [ __ ]
damn they got bet God that we should
started giving her [ __ ] about how she
used the word rumble nobody uses that
and she says like that's what then these
people do Vietnamese people [ __ ] I've
never heard of enemies people say I want
a voter Rumble you me later you and I
Rumble outside Rumble the jungle you
just kind of came in with you didn't it
they got bad wolf cub analysis is the
Vietnamese people I thought it was them
I grew up in a very I guess like you
could say somewhat of a very violent
neighborhood so the way we saw problem
was always put that first and when I was
small T was in elementary school I got
removed out of the school because I
stabbed a kid in the face with a pencil
write to the chief thank you was right
here BAM oh you want to rumble when you
and your husband get into a fight and
car rumbles yeah public ties doing
rubble this week Rumble all the time we
put on our 1920s boxing gloves and then
we get our mustaches that we started
hurling them and then we get me high
from around here
you want a wrassle tassel i was grass
with myself a nice little deer the other
thing Oh y'all frustrated because of
something you put it for too much you
started attacking me out of nowhere okay
doc all right let's get him out of here
Ellen that's that's the thing about free
if you ever get with the Korean woman
just know that at least six times a
month you're gonna get your ass beat for
absolutely no reason
absolutely right now well listen thirty
thirty I actually asked Ellen to help me
out and putting the goes like a screw
that you put into the GoPro so you could
mount it to the car I'm Anthony she
could have figured all not doing Rob oh
damn I gotta say this experience was
very challenging because it is
definitely about one of my Forte's it's
not something that I do
the closest thing that I ever got to do
anything was when I gave a girl lap
dance and I broke her kneecaps but yeah
if you guys want to go ahead and check
her out her link is gonna be in the
description box below
and you could see a master out of craft
so you know I got to thank Ella for even
taking a chance on teaching me that [ __ ]
because for sure if somebody came up to
me and was like hey can you teach me I'd
be a stand-up comedian I'll be like
listen [ __ ] No
you